[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 9 octobre bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 les titres
de cette édition visite officielle ce
matin laura flessel s'est rendu au
château de versailles la ministre des
sports a assisté à la présentation des
sites olympiques d'équitation et de
pentathlon moderne qui seront installés
au monument yvelinois pendant les jo de
pendant tout le mois c est octobre rose
31 jours pour sensibiliser sur le cancer
du sein qui tue près de 12000 femmes
chaque année en france
dans ce journal focus sur le dépistage
est essentielle dans la guérison et nous
parlons également d'une action solidaire
hip hop pink party au programme demain à
maurepas
enfin vendredi se dérouler les 24 heures
du bâtiment une journée dédiée au
secteur au palais des congrès de paris
que faut-il retenir de cette édition
quelle est la situation actuelle du
bâtiment dans le département
pierre cojan président de la fédération
française du bâtiment des yvelines est
notre invité ils veulent ils veulent la
ligne 18 dès 2024 samedi plusieurs élus
des yvelines se sont rassemblés à la
gare des chantiers de versailles dans le
cortège valérie pécresse président de la
région le député didier baichère ou
encore le sénateur michel laugier pour
demander l'avancement de la réalisation
du tronçon yvelinois prévu pour le
moment à l'horizon 2030
après des rumeurs de suppression du
projet le gouvernement a confirmé le
tracé mais pourrait reporter sa
réalisation dans un courrier adressé au
préfet de région valérie pécresse met en
garde sur l'impact catastrophique d'une
telle décision
versailles où la ministre des sports
laura flessel s'est rendu ce matin
l'ancienne championne des scream est
allé au château de versailles sur les
futurs sites olympiques qui
accueilleront les épreuves d'équitation
et de pentathlon moderne nicolas
kirillovitch étaient sur place
il n'y a encore que de l'herbe avec une
vue imprenable sur le château de
versailles dans quelques années
sept ans précisément les cavaliers et
leurs montures s'affronteront ici pour
les épreuves d'équitation djo laura
flessel la ministre des sports est venu
visiter les futurs sites olympiques du
château de versailles qui doit
accueillir également le pentathlon
moderne
on a cette chance de valoriser gérer le
château de versailles géré au niveau
international lorsqu'on va aller partir
à l'international va nous poser des
questions sur les lieux qui vont
recevoir les jeux et aujourd'hui le
château de versailles je connaissais
mais lorsqu'on a cette transposition et
qu'on voit à gérer comment on va
utiliser à gérer pour le futur on est
fiers déjà l'un des sites les plus
visités de france le château de
versailles profitera forcément de
l'effet jo si les travaux n'ont pas
débuté le projet pas encore totalement
arrêtée
des tribunes seront construites pour
accueillir jusqu'à 20000 personnes
de quoi craindre d'éventuelles
dégradations des lieux mais la direction
la sueur et rassure
l'histoire du monument sera préservé si
on s'engage évidemment à respecter tout
l'intégrité de ce lieu je crois même que
ça n'a pas fait la moindre discussion
pour personne quand les membres du cio
sont venus ici
il connaissait le château de versailles
il voyait que c'est ce lieu était resté
dans son intégrité depuis xviiie siècle
qu'on ne pouvait rien n'est changé
en plus du château de versailles le
département des yvelines accueillera
d'autres épreuves olympiques notamment
celle du cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
l'histoire entre benoît hamon et le ps
est définitivement terminée après avoir
quitté le parti pour lancer son
mouvement en juillet l'ancien candidat à
la présidentielle laisse également le
groupe socialiste au conseil régional
avec neuf autres élus dont sandrine
grand grande première secrétaire fédéral
du ps des yvelines
il rejoint le groupe europe ecologie les
verts raisons avancées être plus fort
pour bâtir en commun une décision qui
passe mal auprès de quelques socialistes
yvelinois dont amoureuse à du var
interrogé par nicolas landry souci de
cohérence mais aussi pour assurer
reconstruction en toute sérénité
chapelle et je ne suis pas le seul mais
hier dans cette démarche-là grand bang
quitte ses fonctions de première
secrétaire fédérale 78 puisqu'elle n'est
plus légitime et par la même occasion
elle démissionne du spécialiste puisque
son choix et à fait claire
lui demande également la mise en place
d'une direction collégiale à la tête du
ps des yvelines en attendant le congrès
sandrina grand gambetta la tête de cette
fédération
depuis 2000 12 54 mille nouveaux cas
détectés chaque année en france le
cancer du sein est le plus meurtrier
chez les femmes une sur huit sera touché
au cours de sa vie par la maladie
pourtant une détection précoce sauvent
des vies la maladie est guéri neuf fois
sur dix tout le mois c'est octobre rose
c'est un moment de sensibilisation
justement sur le dépistage reportage au
centre hospitalier de versailles de
nicolas landry et mélanie poker dont moi
j'ai offert même en juillet les narnia
jo 2016
un petit cancer du sein droit avec un
traitement conservateur consultations de
suivi pour cette patiente le cancer du
sein est le plus répandu des cancers
féminins
il touche une femme sur huit en france
il faut que la patiente soit suivi c'est
ce qu'on leur conseille régulièrement
annuellement
par leur gynécologue traitant qui
pratique un examen clinique des seins
d'examen ma mère puis un examen
gynécologique et qui peut soit dépistée
quelque chose soit en tout cas être
attentif aux facteurs de risque de la
patiente et l'adresser faire ça
mammographie et son échographie à titre
individuel ces deux praticiens reçoivent
conjointement des patients adressés par
des confrères après un premier examen
la palpation annuelle est la première
étape d'un dépistage la mammographie
elle permet de révéler les tumeurs le
dépistage permet de diagnostiquer des
lésions très petit qu'on appelle des
lésions infraclinique c'est à dire
qu'elle pourrait pas être perçu ni par
la patiente elle même ni par un médecin
lors d'un examen
c'est là
des visages mammographie qui permet de
détecter ces très petites lésions et qui
permet donc des prises en charge un
stade très précoce
chaque année 54 mille nouveaux cas sont
détectés en france une fois par semaine
à versailles oncologue médecin nucléaire
ou encore radiologue concernés se
rassemblent et on a discuté aujourd'hui
de madame
d'une jeune patiente de 37 ans qui s'est
auto palper un nodule donc fait une
mammographie comme les nodules et est
suspect et le radiologue lui ai fait une
biopsie et j'ai revu avec le résultats
de la biopsie qui est retrouvé un cancer
du sein l'objectif de ces réunions sont
discutées de la prise en charge des
patients avec l'oeil des différents
spécialistes qui voit à chaque fois la
maladie sous un angle différent sur les
possibilités thérapeutiques dans le
domaine qui concerne justement le
médecin qui discutent du dossier
l'intérêt étant d'assurer la meilleure
prise en charge du patient
les médecins du centre hospitalier de
versailles opère une centaine de
patients de chaque année un cancer
détecté à un stade précoce peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 en 2016 seule
une femme sur deux se faisait des pistes
et on accueille sur ce plateau deux
invités delphine et ce par la bonsoir
vous êtes membre de l'association de
dance delight est taillé bonsoir vous
êtes professeur de hip hop à cette
association dit l'aïe delight qui
organise hip hop pink party c'est un
stage de découverte festif aux pros au
profit de la lutte contre le cancer du
sein c'est au gymnase à des baissière de
maurepas de 20h30 à 22h demain les fonds
seront reversés à la ligue contre le
cancer
alors avant de parler de cet événement
petite réaction peut être sur le sujet
que l'on vient de voir
delphine on voudra on vous a
diagnostiqué vous un cancer du sein à 31
ans vous êtes aujourd'hui rétabli le
dépistage c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel dépistage précoce de la
maladie
alors en fait avant 50 ans il n'y a pas
de réelle dépistage surtout si on
présente pas de risque particulier de
concerts nombreux dans la famille et
c'est donc avant 50 ans faut vraiment
être vigilante et pas hésité surtout à
consulter au moindre doute à la moindre
grosseur au moindre au moindre doute
en fait voilà il faut pas hésiter moi ça
voilà j'ai été touché j'avais 31 ans
donc j'étais complètement hors du
circuit des dépistages
systématique et voilà les personnes à
risque parce qu'en fait 90% des cancers
touchent des personnes de plus de 40 ans
et mais malheureusement il ya aussi
beaucoup
enfin de plus en plus de cancers qui
touchent les femmes jeunes voire très
jeunes donc jeunes à 30 ans voire voir -
également vigilance de tout âge donc il
faut tout le primordial exact donc
delight the lady qui organise demain set
hip hop pink party donc un événement au
profit de la lutte contre le cancer du
sein
pourquoi oui pourquoi organiser cet
événement festif pour sensibiliser
peut-être autour de la maladie de base
c'est parti sur une idée de delphine qui
voulait vraiment s'investir sur ce ce
mouvement-là et bas étant l écoute en
avant une chair aussi des actions
caritatives
on s'est dit bah tiens c'est une
adhérente
on a un bon feeling avec elle voilà elle
s'était confiée par rapport à sa maladie
de l'époque par rapport à un mouvement
qu'elle m'avait dit qu'elle arrivait pas
effectué à l'époque discrètement il dit
bah faut la soutenir là dedans on y va
les gars c'est parti donc voila tout
l'association s'est relayée et a mis en
place cet événement là d'ailleurs
delphine le oui le sport c'est quelque
chose de primordial pour repartir dans
la vie en fait il a été démontré
également que en fait la reprise d'une
activité sportive après la maladie
diminuer sensiblement les risques de
récidive en fait le hip hop pour moi
c'est quelque chose dont j'ai toujours
rêvé et en fait c'est l'après cancer qui
m'a vraiment poussé à oser pousser la
porte d'une asso c'est pouvoir danser en
fait donc ça a lié un vieux rêve plus en
fait un réel à réel bénéfice pour ma
santé
un mot aussi peut-être sur l'association
delight qui organise cet événement une
association de danse hip hop à maurepas
voilà en fait une association d'amis en
fait qui à l'époque j'avais des cours
l'association pour laquelle j'en ai des
cours a fermé donc les anciens adhérents
sont montés en bureau pour pouvoir
continuer à apprendre la danse est donc
là sur cet événement là bas ils sont mis
aussi en collaboration sur la
communication avec flora booking donc
voilà ce qu'ont fait une bonne équipe en
collaboration nombreux pour s éclater
ben justement qu'est-ce que vous nous
avez concocté pour demain quel est le
programme deux mois le programme en fait
c'est tout simple on a choisi déjà là
une musique en amont et je viendrai
directement sur l'événement demain et
puis je verrai je ferai une série de pas
pour commencer voir comment ça se passe
si les gens arrivent à intégrer les spas
ou pas et puis au fur et à mesure je
montrais une chorégraphie comme ça en
live
donc c'est un événement aussi bien pour
les membres de l'asso que pour des gens
alors voilà faut savoir tout on a aussi
des adhérents qui sont très jeune ça
commence à 6,7 en est une autre
comment dire le le plus ancien de nos
membres
quand même 76 ans donc ça fait ça doit
faire six ou sept ans qui danse avec
nous voilà donc si les gens sales et
rennes de venir danser le hip hop et rap
à la difficulté et/ou faut pas
s'inquiéter aussi comme un style
vraiment où à tout public d'accord voilà
bien il ya un dresscode d'ailleurs
demain oui tout à fait ses blagues
pingret au moins une touche de rose mais
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait un peu une
unité pour vraiment fédérer tout le
monde autour de la cause et comment on
participe justement à cet événement je
crois qu'on peut s'inscrire en amont ou
s'inscrit enfin revenir directement sur
place tout à fait donc en fait ya un
événement qui a été créé sur facebook
avec différents liens dont le fils le
site s'affiche d'ailleurs pour nos
téléspectateurs
donc en fait il y aura un lien enfin
dans les vêtements facebook on trouve un
lien qui correspond à la billetterie
cancan fait en prévente on est sur une
participation à 10 euros sur place s'il
reste de la place bien sûr on
demanderait une participation de 15
euros sachant que la totalité de ces
sommes seront reversés à la ligue pour
les personnes qui ne veulent pas venir
ne peuvent pas et qui souhaite quand
même soutenir la cause on a aussi créé
une cagnotte en fait sur litchi pour que
les gens puissent aussi donner
directement
donc on peut retrouver le lien également
sur la page facebook de dollars sur
l'événement lui-même tout et d'indiquer
et
voilà il y aura aussi une urne pour ceux
qui veulent donner encore un petit peu
plus le soir de l'événement la question
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
pour cet événement demain bas
un maximum de fonds pour pour lutter
contre le cancer et du fun et d'iphones
alors eh bien merci à vous deux belles
finales et ce par là et taille je
rappelle adhérentes est également donc
professeur de l'association delight
l'organisent demain le hip hop pink
party c'est un cours de hip hop au
profit de la lutte contre le cancer du
sein
rendez vous de 20h30 à 22 heures au
gymnase des baissière à maurepas
yvelines environnement revient avec son
jeu concours cette année le thème étudié
par les enfants sera nos amis les
prairies à cette occasion l'association
en collaboration avec l'éducation
nationale a organisé une journée de
formation des professeurs ils ont pu
ainsi eux aussi découvrir ou re
découvrir l'écosystème des prairies
patrick jacques de dixmude et les arrêts
ch
si vous avez une petite faim c'est lors
du goûter ça s'appelle de la sonel a
sonné c'est le fruit de l'aubépine donc
l'homme préhistorique c'est ce qu'ils
mangent et c'est parti pour une après
midi découverte entre professeurs des
écoles il y en a plus beaucoup donc
voilà c'est pareil c'est une espèce
menacée cette année à travers son jeu
concours l'association yvelines
environnement va faire découvrir les
prairies et leur écosystème
notre but est de donner aux enseignants
et aux centres aérés
du département les éléments qui leur
permettent une réflexion sur un thème
d'environnement nous avons choisi la
prairie car la prairie est un écosystème
qui est particulièrement riche
le rendez-vous permet de former et de
faire connaître aux enseignants un
nouvel univers
j'ai alors j'ai appris beaucoup sur
l'écosystème des prairies vraiment toute
cette biodiversité qu'on peut avoir
c'est tout je savais pas qu'il y avait
beaucoup de preuves et qui était fait
artificiellement pour moi c'était
vraiment du 100% naturels souvent
friands de ces ateliers
ils vont ainsi travailler de manière
ludique avec leur classe tout en les
sensibilisant aux questions
environnementales et a toujours une
dimension écologique qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire nous en tant qu'enfant qu'est
ce qui se passe comment vous avez le
faire vous quand vous allez vous
promener donc parler de bardos pas jeter
les déchets des petites choses comme ça
les professeurs ont encore quelques
semaines pour préparer les travaux
qu'ils feront avec leur classe le
concours se tiendra du 11 janvier au 7
avril prochain ils ont lieu tous les
quatre ans les 24 heures du bâtiment
c'est l'occasion de parler du secteur
mais aussi d'alerter à les pouvoirs
publics l'édition 2017 se tenait
vendredi au palais des congrès de paris
bonsoir pierre cojan président de la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines dressons déjà un petit bilan de
ces 24 heures du bâtiment alors sans
parler des annonces des manuels macro on
va y venir dans un instant emmanuel
macron président de la république qui
est venue sur place pour cette édition
2010 est ya eu trois mille cinq cents
participants
la délégation yvelinoise elle était
composée de 200 personnes oui également
le concert de d'alain souchon et laurent
voulzy c'est cette tare rendez vous
réussi c'était parfait on a une matinée
assez intense où chaque métier a pu
débattre sur le sou l'information sur
tout ce qui se fait dans le bâtiment et
on a eu notre président qui est venu
nous voir en fin de matinée viser nos
stands et on a une journée vraiment
sympathique
c'est un événement qui se déroule tous
les quatre ans l'important ça pour le
bâtiment faire ces 24 heures ça permet
de faire un bilan de le faire un bilan
sur tous les ans on fait dans une ag est
quand même tous ensemble mais ça permet
de donner quatre ans pour voir un peu ce
qui a été fait puisque ont à faire dans
les quatre prochaines années et on a eu
la visite en plus de l'après midi du du
ministre du terril taurian jacques
mézard et son secrétaire d'état
julien d'amendis qui ont été vraiment
aller coûte c'est ce qu'on a pu
apprécier et ont même suivi une partie
nous débat super intéressant alors
visite vous l'avez dit également sur
place du président de la république
emmanuel macron l'occasion pour lui de
faire quelques annonces sur le secteur
en l'occurrence sur des mesures du plan
logement qui ont été retoqués par
exemple il n'est plus question de
supprimer immédiatement le ptz qui le
prêt à taux zéro pour l'achat d'un
logement neuf dans les zones les moins
tendues de france finalement voilà
emmanuel macron a annoncé proposer dhabi
c'est ce montant maximum du du ptz
accordés par accordés par la banque
il pourrait atteindre 20 % de
l'empreinte totale contre 40%
aujourd'hui c'est une mesure comment
comment vous l'accueillez cette mesure
nous tous qui était jusqu'à maintenant
on peut que s'en réjouir
bon le
on a eu le le prêt à taux zéro c'est
comme ça c'est important parce que pour
les nouveaux acquis les nouveaux
acquéreurs et hélas dans les zones
tendues c'est repoussé pour deux ans on
a eu ça on a eu le cee qui devaient être
supprimés
le crédit d'impôt pour la transition au
niveau des défauts net et chaudières
c'est une catastrophe parce que pour
nous nos petites entreprises posent à
deux têtes où on insisté avant de la
fenêtre de l'économie d'énergie est là
maintenant ça va il va falloir sa sortie
progressive esquisser des voeux mais ça
va se faire bon c'est quand même
agréable d'être entendus et ça on peut
l'apprécier
c'est une des annonces qui ont été
offensés et iront dans le bon sens ont
ils ont pris des réformes bon il ya ça
dès qu'on a accepté y en a d'autres
moins et après on a pu en discuter c'est
ce qui est important ce jour a été
évoquée également l'ouverture de
discussions avec l'union sociale de
l'habitat au sujet des allocations
logement alors le but c'est d'aboutir à
des logements sociaux et un dispositif
moins coûteux et plus efficace oui parce
que ils se sont rendus compte que le cd
des gens de bureaucratie qui organisait
tous et toutes ces choses là et so did
in one aux besoins de logements sociaux
vous êtes des constructeurs et des
bâtisseurs on a résultats sachez
d'obtenir donc on des partis là-dessus
lui nous font confiance à steve aux
ladres bâtir ensemble
dernière chose sur ces annonces la venue
d'emmanuel macron il ya eu un engagement
aussi pris sur un débat pour la
diminution des normes de construction
quelles sont ces quelles sont ses
engagements quelles pistes ont été
évoquées
oui parce qu'en fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on
veut on veut un résultat on ne va pas
faire n'importe quoi dans le bâtiment
mais il ya tellement de hors norme sur
normes
ça pose beaucoup de difficultés les
difficultés financières et donc
maintenant on va essayer de faire de
trahir mieux à mon cher si possible mais
c'est le résultat qui compte et plus des
normes que nous impose alors les 24
heures du bâtiment c'est aussi bien sur
le moment pour dresser un petit peu la
situation du secteur tels et tels en
france plus particulièrement dans les
yvelines vous êtes vous président de la
ffbb des yvelines
et est ce que le bâtiment est dans une
bonne phase
ça repart le contraire c'est ce qui est
bien c'est ça oui c'était pas mal depuis
au moins 8 à 10 ans là ça repart depuis
un an un an et demi
et surtout d'un logement neuf dans le
jaune d'oeuf c'est pas trop non plus une
entreprise du bâtiment 85% cette petite
entreprise donc là ce niveau là on a du
mal à ressentir l'amélioration mais bon
on y croit on pense maintenant je pense
que si le gouvernement applique des
choses prn et et qu'on change pas tous
les quatre matins comme ça plus de
physique et maintenant où c'est pas
évident je pense qu'il faut donner
confiance aux entreprises
et puis aussi aux clients parce que les
gens n'auraient pu investir entre l'ailé
la fiscalité qui changent tous bonne
chance un peu embêtant quoi vous parlez
d'une reprise légère reprise c'est déjà
repris c'est quelque chose de fragile
c'est sûr l'on peut et sait fragile même
ses fans attentes mais les gens en vie
mais faut leur donner le la répulsion et
puis créer un fil rouge pour que ça
devienne pérenne la reprise pour tout le
monde
merci à pierre cojan d'avoir été avec
nous j'aurais pu vous êtes le président
de la fédération française du bâtiment
18 mai pour plus d'infos sur cette
fédération vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran du sport on vous en parlait la
semaine dernière dans le 7-8 journal
golf expérience était organisée samedi
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus de 600 personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour s'initier gratuitement
à la discipline et découvrir également
le village en avant-première ce village
ambulant de la ryder cup 2018 qui
s'exportera dans toutes les villes du
territoire michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas kirillovitch
ce samedi 7 octobre yasmine neuf ans à
travailler son swing sous l'oeil de son
père au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
elle fait partie des six ans novice qui
ont participé à cette sixième édition de
la golf expérience un événement gratuit
encadrés par des experts
l'idée langue puis c'était plutôt rigolo
les facile qu'il a présentée via des
bals où j'ai réussi des bals où j'ai pas
réussi c'est très très très bien c'est
très bien et je pense qu'il faut il
pouvoir faire ce genre de l'expérience
encore souvent la renouveler depuis les
inciter à leur donner envie leur donner
envie de taper dans la balle pour aider
les novices le joueur confirmé à
progresser des capteurs ont été
installés sur les différents ateliers
objectif les aider à améliorer le jeu
long et le jeu court avec ça on va
pouvoir aider le joueur
à travailler les bons points aller
travailler dans le bon sens pas aller
dans un chemin qui va pas être le bon
pour le joueur corrigé plus facilement
les défauts du joueur avec des données
mathématiques tous les coûts devraient
être bons et précis donc c'est important
de bien se connaître soi même d'avoir
tous les paramètres qui influent sur la
performance en parallèle des activités
sportives les golfeurs en herbe ont pu
découvrir en avant première un village
ambulant dédié à la ryder cup 2018 qui
se déroulera au golf national
le but c'est de parler aux saint
quentinois et leur expliquer ce qu'est
la ryder cup justement donc on a toutes
une tente de promotion où on parle
souvent de la ryder cup on à la
documentation à remettre aux visiteurs
on a une tante qui détient la réalité
virtuelle
enfin c'est une visite virtuelle du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
par les saint quentinois sont jamais
venus sur ce site exceptionnel
on leur propose du coup d'une manière
très immersive il est très émotionnel de
découvrir ce site à partir de novembre
ce village ambulant va s'exporter à
l'extérieur des frontières du golf
national 20 événements sont déjà
programmés sur 11 communes de 50 ans et
demi jusqu'à l'organisation de la ryder
cup en septembre 2018 au rugby pour son
deuxième match de la saison en promotion
d'honneur montigny le bretonneux
enregistre une nouvelle défaite 8 à 11 à
domicile face à l'équipe de garches
résumé du match avec camille lambert et
nicolas dandois deuxième match deuxième
défaite de la saison pour montigny le
bretonneux lésigny montain se sont
inclinés de justesse 8 à 11 à la maison
face à garches une partie équilibrée
entre les deux équipes
ça s'est joué sur des petits détails et
voilà le groupe pour l'instant pas été
capables de
de gagner par rapport à ces détails mais
voilà on reste positif et puis on va
travailler pour faire la différence
pourtant les inimités ont bien entamé la
rencontre après avoir ouvert le score
sur une pénalité montigny le bretonneux
inscrire le premier essai du match le
demi de mêlée ouvre le deuxième centre
prend l'intervalle raffûte et aplatit
derrière la ligne 8 à 0 pour les verts
mes gars réagi les rouge et blanc
s'installe dans les 22 mètres de
montigny plusieurs maul lésigny montain
multiplient les fautes et finissent par
payer car je reviens à trois longueurs
juste avant la mi temps lors de la
seconde période la tension monte d'un
cran
larbitre distribuer plusieurs cartons
suite à des fautes répétées les gars
choix reviennent au score et passe
devant grâce à deux pénalités montigny
le bretonneux aurait pu l'emporter mais
l'essai est finalement refusé par
l'arbitré suite à un contact entre deux
joueurs il y monte à 2 en parlant qu'on
a encore des matches à domicile on va
chez les joueurs et les équipes qui
étaient en 1re série avec nous l'année
dernière donc on compte aller gagner à
extérieur on compte gagner nos matchs à
domicile mais maintenant on va pas
lâcher lors de questions
montigny le bretonneux se retrouve à la
8e place aux portes de la zone rouge
prochain match dimanche face au deuxième
du classement sur le terrain de saint
maur
demain journée de mouvement dans la
fonction publique à l'appel de neuf
syndicats mouvements qui va se ressentir
également dans les communes du
territoire plusieurs écoles seront
fermées
un service d'accueil minimum sera assuré
à maurepas elancourt notamment un repas
froid sera servi aux écoliers de plaisir
ou la restauration scolaire est
également concernée pour plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rapprocher de vos communes et pour
conclure ce journal une disparition
celle de l'acteur jean rochefort à l'âge
de 87 ans acteur mais aussi cavalier il
possédait une propriété le haras de
ville quoi dans la commune d'auffargis
dans les yvelines
les habitants se souviennent écoutez les
au micro de nicolas landry il passait
d'un au phare j ai je me souviens à ce
moment en voiture d'ailleurs et je me
souviens à ce moment là je l'avais salué
à plusieurs reprises et finalement et
répondez avec le sourire de façon tout à
fait sympathique vague d'orages forts
des fois je vais là haut
les cobayes à la ferme blanche parce
qu'il était là haut pour venir chercher
sa paille pour ces jo c'est quand je
monte là où dans les bois on
l'apercevait à mesure des bois
il faisait il prenait les chemins et
pistes en exergue son cheval c'était à
l'ouverture de notre magasin proxi
c'était un samedi matin monsieur jean
rochefort a eu la gentillesse de venir
avec un petit panier au bras et
d'accueillir les personnes du village de
les saluer il savait que ça leur faisait
plaisir de le rencontrer c'est la fin de
ce set 8 journal retrouvé le replay et
nos reportages sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile tv 78 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]